priorité au direct c'est un scénario
inhabituel qui se déroule heures sous
l'oeil des caméras de bfm tv
une voiture folle qui semble ne pas
vouloir s'arrêter et qui a déjà causé de
nombreux dégâts sur l'autoroute d'albi
17 ans john monsieur d'amélie c'est ce
qu'on fait pour désactiver le régulateur
de vitesse et suffit de freiner sa le
désactive automatiquement
on ne peut pas s'arrêter dans la boîte à
fusibles
thème peut-on voiture soit sur le ton
plus ferme est bloqué bazooka et après
notre sol et pas trop capitaine savoir
un peu d'humour besoins en capital
des couleurs dans ce circuit on pourra
trouver une solution et plus
si tu as la joie au coeur tape dans tes
mains les enchante peut sauver ce mardi
marie gillain je viens de parler avec
les services techniques
mais touchant sert résiduelles devait en
sortir aucune
ah les pompiers prague fait sa mue
autoroute info tous les coups